[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que l'association
communautaire centre-sud dans laquelle
vous avez investi beaucoup de temps et
d'argent pour vous c'est une façon de
boucler la boucle pendant votre retraite
parce que tout jeune n'avait pas fini
votre 11e année mais des gens qui vous
encourager un moment oui absolument
j'ai eu la chance et la malchance en
même temps de chômer pays de l'ocs mon
père m'a dit quand on à l'école où
travaillent bon alors qu'elle se trouve
un job
et puis par magie je me suis retrouvé
réseau canada 53 quoi débuts de la télé
là et là je voyais un monde mais ça
arrive rien mon dieu que c'est pour des
gens qui parlaient de la fed de
philosophie de et tout le monde et l
autre passage parce qu'il y avait des
bus dans la vie mounabah on essaie de
mettre les jeunes doivent à toutes
sortes de possibilités
le potentiel pour être là tu vois ça
c'est sûr et la bibliothèque est où 20
livres trouve un univers c'est fabuleux
alors 16 on est là pour qu'à la fin
jusqu'à maintenant on va être là fait du
chemin a dit oui a dit non a dit non on
vous l'a dit oui a dit non tu pensé
comme l'a dit oui comme le dit non et
pendant toute votre carrière vous avez
fait cet humour au look de ces
féministes mais c'est de faire passer
des messages et j'ai un peu l'impression
que vous essayez toujours avec vos
sketches ainsi que tout le monde sait
maintenant oui vous avez été aimé par
beaucoup de gens votre carrière l'humain
absolument
moi j'ai été mais on est tellement aimé
des fois c'est pour ça que je pourrais
pas faire le pôle créé parce qu'on est
tellement détestés peut pas accepter ça
non mais on est tellement aimé est
d'ailleurs bon cette année je suis aimé
plus que jamais
quand même aimons nous jouer à lajoux
est maudit
aimons nous
à
parce que ma chanson est mon nom a été
intronisé au temps de les renommer pour
porter nos panthéon des
auteurs-compositeurs aurait pu le on est
très peu de com et remarques je
comprends pas que clémence et pas de ses
chansons déjà tellement des belles
chansons entre c'est moi qu'ils le
premier matin que j'étais à leurs
attaches manière valeur je m'habille
mange mes touches jouées borello votre
première retraite lui au début des
années 80 parce que vous en aviez assez
de la rectitude politique qui vous
alliez assez loin merci je pense au
monologue l'étape est aujourd'hui 11é
toujours la même à face et on fait des
choses en temps puis dans l'espace et
puis il ya des modes et ça mais je suis
certain que j'écrivais aujourd'hui
j'écrirai les mêmes choses
c'est à dire les mêmes thèmes
j'utiliserai je serai aussi arrogant
mais d'une autre façon
les mousses les images très différent
parce que là on peut plus aller aussi
loin qu'on allait la non un trop
sensible il ya des sensibilités ex est
ce trop genre ben bouhout sensible aux
mères dans le partage des tâches et l
affaire d'état toi tu manges
toi tu salis ton neige c'est ça
c'est rassurant pour la nam de voir que
les femmes connaissent bien leurs
conditions pendant toute votre carrière
vous moquer des relations ont une fin
pourtant vous êtes avec la même conjoint
depuis 50 ans ce qui est assez rare dans
le show biz ou et je vous en fait on a
une vie compliquée jo des - puis on
s'est séparés pendant quelques années
mais en même temps on savait qu'on se
met tellement et que c'était important
de gérer
c'est important de voir arriver quelque
part qu'on ne pourrait pas à être si on
ne durait pas on recommence si on
recommence change de femme sur un tour
comme en allant à un moment donné on
s'est dit le plus important c'est que on
veut vieillir ans
mon voeu est ensemble toujours quoiqu'il
arrive donc à partir de ce moment là on
accepte plus on sort c'est juste un
passage le savoir cette semaine ce pas
de pub mais c'est pas grave parce qu'on
était ensemble pour la vie nous aurons
talent et le fait aussi que on s'est
décidé tous les deux d'ailleurs le
moment l'un que l'autre est parfait
l'eau parce qu'on l'ait ndongue et
parfaitement ce qu'on veut que soit donc
ces petits problèmes comme jeter à
johnny n'avait pas des fois leur juste
des qualités exagéré mais c'est qu'elles
exagéraient au moins donné ça devient
agréable si au lieu de fin au non encore
de titre mais nous lui a dit tu penses
pas ce que ça vous monte là son nom
l'enseignement du tout non ma maman qui
pendant plusieurs années
c'est un prix minimum deux à peut-être
plus avant que je sens que je que je
fasse rare c'est fini ça je retournerai
jamais lassé fin et c'est pas que jamais
parce que à un moment donné c'est
tellement stressant parce que je veux
dire une chose pour nous résume henri
c'est un ampli difficile
de toujours écrire toujours se
renouveler mes vieux joe mourinho
charles prochaine le vieil chantant et
ont diffusé mais oui mais moi je peux
pas fermer mieux maintenant autre
exemple credo c'est là qu'est le stress
est ce qu'il sait trop mais vous écrivez
plus j'écris plus tôt je voulais et mais
ça a toujours été comme anderson un
pinceau d'écrire
j'ai toujours été difficile pour moi je
ne faisais pas j'étais obligé parce
qu'il faut se renouveler mais j'ai pensé
qu'elle non je pourrais écrire pour le
plaisir de créer mais j'ai pas c'est
difficile tout le temps yvon deschamps
quel plaisir merci mais je leur ai un
peu brisé mon cher